so new video now also here with a
new account
so that as high as the account in
youtube fits I lost one in experiments
with the software directly in the first
two games and I am
now at 1202 so there is still a long way
to go to
normal correct areas
and let's see
how it goes
english opening
black of course now has many
possibilities
well maybe seen the games from the
candidate competition yes looks like
building up with c55 for black of
course generally very solid
prevents the four
black of course always has to be a
bit careful with him  under
certain circumstances get weak because if the
is no longer a tree
white is actually planning
to use a piece in the long term if possible or
to play how much to play here on the
queenside let's see how
black reacts now the 6
that means he lets me  four play
very often black also plays from 5 onwards in order
to play e.g  u prevent how much
that now first of all progress for
white
now no black for example not
without further ado the want to take off the bishop
we seven would hang after b
bad cd simply zob
75 yes that was of course very direct
at some point it will definitely be part of the
black plan  the question now is what about d
3, the 3 might come e4
and then the knight will hang here
so be careful a bit i think you
can sometimes sacrifice material our
position but i don't think
any of them are like that here what plausible moves
do i have here
i could also pull the sprint out of the line of fire first of all
typical good 2d 3d 5
unusual the whole sequence but
not necessarily bad for
black it would be very interesting to
play
what he did
that you
look i'll make a bishop 6
i  I'll continue here with them with
the rod, yes, he really did it, but
now I actually thought so  I could take c5
and b7 so that's actually
a very good
exchange with the bad c5 pawn
remains but
overall a
strange position of course because I
somehow still have the bishop in here so strangely
you could ask him there immediately there it
would be such an interesting question  now
springer i3 first of all maybe
yes okay that can't be bad
take the
pace erding covered I then here
I didn't think at all I
actually thought only seven runners now then
namely there and there
okay I didn't count
well the hammer  collect anyway so
white has now won a pawn
but it is not so clear
what that means in the position of
the rudolf ac 3e 2 these funny
runners
he always jumps the 4
i make a4 with the idea pregnant
like 5 or maybe also  runner three
if that allows he has now prevented all that
i
would like to try to build
two times here  to reduce
the only good thing about the white spot where
is that the farmers are more off,
otherwise it
is really quite active
but they can also evaporate relatively quickly
and the time yes I have
again slowly like anything else
so that they 6
I can now  the three
can't play twice by the way
dhabi so in the end he
just took a
diagonal position
ok now
but should still actually work runner a3
because i don't find it difficult doing
something is really gone now yes
i can live do that  we'd better
have a look
now if that's best
sinking but away so he
disappears here
now here back with the in de la b 2
so he's getting more and more figure I was just
as usual long like anything else
now runner b 2 games 2  hit
just slide here
to get going now the three methods
that once tie up
it's still bar more much rest
just slowly okay as usual
because more and more
doing
for reasons of simplification,
take the thing away, well
, straight onto it,
but okay, that should be quite
good enough,
it
works like
that, I was so slow, but now it's just
a matter of making a few points,
which somehow comes to the
fore here